for more than 120 years National
Geographic has pioneered new
technologies bold explorations and
stunning new media today this journey
continues on the iPad for the National
Geographic magazine it is a powerful new
showcase a custom-built interactive
version of the full print edition with
brilliant photography motion graphics
and even video it's not about what I'm
doing I'm pretty insignificant in the
whole thing plus all the interactive
favorites already in the magazines
online portfolio but even this is just
the beginning National Geographic maps
have been optimized for the ipad so pick
your country tap and explore listen to
music we can delete those things are
should I say hey man get out of mice
then settle into a wild ride from nat
geo game already downloaded over 10
million times Herod's tomb is better
than ever just like National Geographic
calm all the features photography and
video you come to expect from the
Advertising Age magazine website of the
year has been upgraded for the handheld
digital future
National Geographic on the iPad explore
the world with your fingertips